e
n'est pas le bagage de
l'expérience Dominique Ducharm.
- Après seulement 83 matchs
à la barre du Canadien,
le règne de Dominique Ducharme
est terminé à Montréal.
Insatisfait des performances de
l'équipe, le nouveau directeur
général Kent Hughes a choisi de
lui montrer la porte mercredi.
Le Tricolore est, après tout, en
passe de signer la pire saison
istoire. Il n'a gagné
que huit de ses 45 matchs depuis
le début du calendrier et n'a
connu la victoire qu'une seule
fois depuis le 16 décembre.
Les conmances
de l'équipe pesaient visiblement
sur le moral des joueurs
et un changement était devenu
nécessaire.
MARTIN Lalyste sportif
- Il n'y avait plus de
solutions. Le groupe
ne suivait plus. Il n'y avait
plus d'énergie. Et là,
on pense qu'une nouvelle voix
va peut-être réussir
à restructurer un peu le tout.
- Dominique Ducharme avait été
nommé à la barre du Canadien
de façon intérimaire en février
2021. Sous sa gouverne,
le Tricolore est plore est ploru
à causer la surprise en séries
éliminatoires en atteignant
la finale de la Coupe Stanley
pour la première fois
depuis 1993, l'été dernier.
Cette saison, son équipe aura
toutefois été victime du mauvais
sort. Le capitaine Shea Weber
a pris sa retraite de façon
inopinée et le gardien de bu
Carey Price n'est pas encore
revenu au jeu après avoir eu
recours au programme
d'assistance des joueursde la L.
- Il y a eu une avalanche de
blessures, des éclosions de
COVID... Vous pouvez imaginer
e quelle catastrophe
imaginable, ça s'est abattu
sur le Canadien cette saison.
Alors Dominique Ducharme
n'est pas vraiment à blâmer pour
la performance de son équipe,
mais on voyait...
Les joueurs ont abandonné.
- Seulement quelques heures
après avoir annoncé
le congédiement de Ducharme,
l'organisation a nommé Martin
St-Louis comme entraîneur-chef
par intérim des Canadiens.
L'ancien joueur, âgé de 46 ans,
a obtenu plus de 1000 points
dans la Ligue nationale de
hockey et remporté la Coupe
Stanley en 2004 avec
le Lightning de Tampa Bay.
Il s'agit d'une nouvelle
direction pour l'organisation
qui tente de relancer sa saison.
Ici Raphaël Guillemette,
Radio-Canada, Mon